[Music]
my world
founding LFO member Brian Gillis has
died
it's 47 years old bandmate Brad
fischetti who co-founded LFO with Gillis
shared the news to Instagram telling
fans that he doesn't know how Gillis
died
[Music]
crazy
in his message on Thursday fishetti says
the LFO story is a tragedy a reference
to the fact that LFO had already lost
two other members of the group what's up
I'm Brad I'm rich
Cronin another LFO co-founder died in
2010 following a long battle with
leukemia then in 2018 Devin Lima who
joined LFO after Gillis exited the band
died of adrenal cancer
Gillis known by his nickname brizz
parted ways with LFO before the group
found mainstream success in 1999 with
its debut album without our fans win
nothing and we know that
the Shetty writes in his message that
LFO would not exist if it wasn't for
gillis's hard work and dedication
[Music]